competition it's a fundamental part of
human nature I was a professional poker
player for 10 years so I've very much
seen all the good bad and ugly ways it
can
manifest when it's done right it can
drive us to incredible Feats in sports
and Innovation like when car companies
compete over who can build the safest
cars or the most efficient solar panel
those are all examples of healthy
competition because even though
individual companies might come and go
in the long run the game between them
creates win-win outcomes where everyone
benefits in the end but sometimes
competition is not so great and can
create lose lose outcomes where
everyone's worse off than before take
these AI Beauty filters for example as
you can see they're a very impressive
technology they can salvage almost any
picture they can even make Angelina and
Margot more beautiful so they're very
handy especially for influencers who now
at the click of a button can transform
into the most beautiful Hollywood
versions of themselves but handy doesn't
always mean healthy and I've personally
noticed how quickly these things can
train you to hate your natural face and
there's growing evidence that they're
creating issues like body dysmorphia
especially in young people nonetheless
these things are now endemic to social
media because the nature of the game
demands it the platforms are
incentivized to provide them because
hotter pictures means more hijacked
limic systems which means more scrolling
and thus more ad revenue and users are
incentivized to use them because hotter
pictures get you more followers but this
is a trap because once you start using
these things it's really hard to go back
plus you don't even get a competitive
advantage vage from them anymore because
everyone else is already using them too
so influencers are stuck using these
things with all the downsides and very
little upside a lose lose game a similar
kind of trap is playing out in our news
media right now but with much worse
consequences you'd think since the
internet came along that the increased
competition between news outlets would
create a sort of positive spiral you
know like a race to the top of nuanced
impartial accurate
journalism instead we're seeing a race
to the bottom of clickbait and
polarization where even respectable
papers are increasingly leaning into
these kind of low brow partisan
tactics again this is due to crappy
incentives today we no longer just read
our news we interact with it by sharing
and commenting and headlines that
trigger emotions like fear or anger ER
are far more likely to go viral than
neutral or positive ones so in many ways
news editors are in a similar kind of
trap as the influencers where the more
their competitors lean into clickbaity
tactics the more they have to as well
otherwise their stories just get lost in
the noise but this is terrible for
everybody because now the media get less
trust from the public but also it
becomes harder and harder for anyone to
discern truth from f
which is a really big problem for
democracy now this process of
competition gone wrong is actually the
driving force behind so many of our
biggest
issues plastic pollution
deforestation antibiotic overuse in
farming arms races greenhouse gas
emissions these are all a result of
crappy incentives of poorly designed
games that push their players be then
people companies or governments into
taking strategies and tactics that defer
costs and harms to the
Future and what's so ridiculous is that
most of the time these guys don't even
want to be doing this you know it's not
like packaging companies want to fill
the oceans with plastic or Farmers want
to woren antibiotic resistance but
they're all stuck in the same dilemma of
if I don't use this tactic I'll get outc
competing by all the others who do so I
have to do it
too this is the mechanism we need to fix
as a
civilization and I know what you're
probably all thinking ah so it's
capitalism no it's not capitalism which
yes can cause problems but it can also
solve them and has been fantastic in
general it's something much deeper it's
a force of misaligned incentives of Game
Theory
itself so a few years ago I retired from
poker in in part because I wanted to
understand this mechanism better because
it takes many different forms and it
goes by many different names these are
just some of those names you can see
they're a little bit abstract and clunky
right they don't exactly roll off the
tongue and given how Insidious and
connected all of these problems are it
helps to have a more visceral way of
recognizing
them so this is probably the only time
you're going to hear about the Bible at
this conference but I want to tell you a
quick story from it because allegedly
back in the Canaanite days there was a
cult who wanted money and power so badly
they were willing to sacrifice their
literal children for it and they did
this by burning them alive in an effigy
of a God that they believed would then
reward them for this ultimate
sacrifice and the name of this God was
mik bit of a bummer as stories go but
you can see why it's an apt metaphor
because sometimes we get so lost in
winning the game right in front of us we
lose sight of the bigger picture and
sacrifice too much in our pursuit of
Victory so just like these guys were
sacrificing their children for power
those influencers are sacrificing their
happiness for
likes those news editors are sacrificing
their inte for clicks and polluters are
sacrificing the biosphere for
profit in all these examples the
short-term incentives of the games
themselves are pushing they're tempting
their players to sacrifice more and more
of their future trapping them in a death
spiral where they all lose in the
end that's mullock's trap the mechanism
of unhealthy
competition and the same is now happen
happening in the AI industry we're all
aware of the race that's heating up
between companies right now over who can
score the most compute you know who can
get the biggest funding round or get the
top talent well as more and more
companies enter this race the greater
the pressure for everyone to go as fast
as possible and sacrifice other
important stuff like safety testing this
has all the Hallmarks of a mollock trap
cuz like imagine you're a CEO who you
know in your heart of hearts believe
that your team is the best to be able to
safely build extremely powerful AI well
if you go too slowly then you run the
risk of other much less cautious teams
getting there first and deploying their
systems before you can so that in turn
pushes you to be more Reckless yourself
and given how many different experts and
researchers both Within These companies
but also completely independent ones
have been warning us about the extreme
risks of rushed AI this approach is
absolutely
mad plus almost all AI companies are
beholden to satisfying their investors a
short-term incentive which over time
will inevitably start to conflict with
any benevolent Mission and this wouldn't
be a big deal if this was really just
toasters we're talking about here but Ai
and especially AGI is set to be a bigger
Paradigm Shift than the agricultural or
Industrial Revolutions a moment in time
so pivotal it's deserving of reverence
and reflection not something to be
reduced to a corporate rat race of who
can score the most daily active users
I'm not saying I know what the right
trade-off between acceleration and
safety is but I do know that we'll never
find out what that right trade-off is if
we let mik dictate for
us so what can we do well the good news
is we have managed to coordinate to
escape some of mullock's traps before we
managed to save the ozone layer from
cfc's with the help of the Montreal
protocol we managed to reduce the number
of nuclear weapons on Earth by 80% with
the help of the Strategic arms reduction
treaty in
1991 so smart regulation May certainly
help with AI too but ultimately it's the
players within the game who have the
most influence on it so we need AI
leaders to show us that they're not only
aware of the risks their Technologies
pose but also the destructive nature of
the incentives that they're currently
beholden to as their technological
capabilities reach towards the power of
gods they're going to need the Godlike
wisdom to know how to wield them so it
doesn't fill me with encouragement when
I see a CEO of a very major company
saying something like I want people to
know we we made our competitor dance
that is not the type of mind set we need
here we need leaders who are willing to
flip mik's Playbook who are willing to
sacrifice their own individual chance of
winning for the good of the
whole now fortunately the three leading
labs are showing some signs of doing
this anthropic recently announced their
responsible scaling policy which pledges
to only increase capabilities once
certain security criteria have been met
open AI have recently pledged to
dedicate 20% of their compute purely to
research and Deep Mind have shown a
decade long focus of science ahead of
Commerce like their development of
alfold which they gave away to the
science Community for
free these are all steps in the right
direction but they are still nowhere
close to being enough I mean most of
these are currently just words they're
not even proven
actions so we need a clear way to turn
the AI race into a definitive race to
the top perhaps perhaps companies can
start competing over who can be you know
within these metrics over who can
develop the best security criteria a
race of who can dedicate the most to
compute to alignment now that would
truly flip the middle finger to
mik competition can be an amazing tool
provided we wield it wisely and we're
going to need to do that because the
stakes we are playing for are
astronomical if we get AI and especially
AGI wrong it could lead to unimaginable
catastrophe but if we get it right it
could be our path out of many of these M
traps that I've mentioned
today and as things get crazier over the
coming years which they're probably
going to it's going to be more important
than ever that we remember that it is
the Real Enemy here mik not any
individual CEO or company and certainly
not one another so don't hate the
players change the
game